thank you yes sir I was joined in the
studio by the former world champion
Alexandre castenuk Alexandra
congratulations you just won a very
interesting game because uh well let's
have a look at the opening and I wanted
to ask you how do you choose those
openings you know everything so why
Queen D4 and queen D3 today
I wish I would know everything but well
just to surprise my opponent because
recently I played in the process league
for my team and
Alexander Shimano there one was this
opening against Magnus Carson so I said
that if it's possible to win against
Magnus costume why not try it
myself so yeah I think Arena played very
well much better than Marcus Castle no
but I'm kidding it was just different
move order so it was not the same line
but I think she played well the position
was equal
uh but then at the moment when she
played queen 2b4 I'm not sure it was
forced or not maybe let's have a look at
this position first because it seemed
that she equalized comfortably but the
position is still full of life and I
like this move Bishop H5 because well it
seems that the position is equal but you
need to find moves and very precise
moves here so yeah of course I mean she
has a very strong Concentra center but
her King's position is a little bit
weaker and I was happy when we kind of
exchanged the spawn Center because yeah
well it's quite clear that the position
should be around equal but again sensor
Kink has more open it's more difficult
for her to play yeah and after Queen H4
she played Queen 2 before I consider
this move I don't know if it was like
really necessary and again we ended up
in this um
and game which is yeah I think the main
line is Rook A8 instead of Rook seat
Well at least that's what
probably it's the same but Knight takes
before bishop f8 and my idea was to play
Knight D3
then she like captures captures how I
didn't see Rook A5 like well Rook takes
a two Rook D7 and I'm winning a pawn but
again it's like opposite colored Bishops
and probably after Bishop C5 it should
be a draw
um but I mean it's always nice to play
with an extra Pawn right you're not
risking anything and every mistake can
be fatal for my opponent so I mean I
liked your idea to exchange the Rooks
but at the same time here I have like a
plan I can play on two sides trying you
know to create a past phone then attack
the F7 pawns and that's what happened in
the game I'm not sure
actually I'm not sure about Knight xc5 I
was very scared of course to get into
this opposite colored uh
um end game because okay without the
pawn on E6 it's a winning game but with
the pawn on E6 I was kind of scared a
little bit because I don't have to I
thought that I was going actually to
play Knight A7 and something like Bishop
D4 Knight C8 and then
um if she plays Knight C4 I I can play
B5 I mean kind of get also opposite
colored bishop and game but a little bit
improved with a few Tempe but then okay
I calculated and I thought that it
should be winning so that's why I went
to it well but we thought that here
especially after 95 you spent uh well 10
to 12 minutes I think but probably
mostly to recover that Arena made her
last move and she had only one second
left oh no it was calculating I was not
sure about the evolution I mean again
without the pawn on E6 it's uh should be
winning but there are some positions who
knows I mean you never know you're I
mean you really need to calculate uh the
hat and you're scared you know because
it's clear that I have an advantage here
and I don't have to take on E5 right I
can keep the knights on the board and
she has 30 min seconds and it's so
difficult to play with against those two
past Pawns but okay then I forced myself
to calculate a little bit
thank you Alexander that was a very
important Victory especially for the
standings so uh well you don't have a
free day so that's a fight and well you
have three more important important
rounds to come
Alexandra a quick question for you were
you aware that Arena on several
occasions
made and pressed her clock with one
second twice I think twice Knight E5 and
then there was another move but it
was not about the uh clock here but
about the evolution I think of the
position so I didn't sometimes yeah I
mean I've had
um
several uh moments like this when my
opponent made uh like uh their moves on
on the last seconds and it kind of
distracted me but in that case it's hard
to distract race it's it's either a
winning end game or uh drone end game so
it didn't it didn't distract but yeah
not this time
uh congratulations a very important
Victory indeed as Alexandra best's Arena
Crush in a key game a key matchup yeah
nothing very instructive truly truly